d'abord ya un signal très fort qui était
donné en côte d'or non seulement par la
réfection de ce qui était déjà élu et
qui ont été réélu brillamment je pense à
mon gamin de mon ami à la je suis
content aussi de bernard pot qui est élu
maire de vitteaux dans un endroit qui
m'est chère avec plus de 60% des voix
donc c'est une belle victoire là aussi
et puis on le voit bien montbard qui
bascule et sur tille qui bascule c'est à
dire voilà ce sont des bonnes nouvelles
pour quelque part aussi pour la france
ça monte que l'alternative politique est
en route l'alternance est en route et on
le verra pour les prochains scrutins
ça montre aussi que le débat qu'ont
apporté vraiment d'opposition mais de
position aussi en attente de jours
meilleurs pour la france c'est un débat
qu'on apporte etc était utile pour les
français quand on a combattu la réforme
territoriale
on voit des cantons qui ont basculé
parce qu'ils ne comprennent pas les
réformes qu'on a imposé à marche forcée
y compris pour les territoires et ce
débat-là été portée parfois même en
dehors des médias mais en tout cas chez
les habitants croyez moi il ya eu
vraiment une volonté de dire voilà on va
adresser un signal donc ce message de la
côte d'or ça message très fort puis
l'époque le côte-d'orien je me réjouis
de ce qui se passe en bourgogne vous
avez vu à sens j'étais allé aussi
soutenir sa demande mardi soir caf un
score formidable qu'elle gagne il va
gagner les murs car auxerre jeu égal
mâcon le maire confortée au chalon qui
tombent pas franchement voilà c'est une
belle soirée une belle soirée pour la
conditionner inverse de 2008 d'ailleurs
à écouter en 2008 je pensais que vous
avez encore du chemin à faire pour
convaincre les français c'est vrai parce
qu'on avait engagé des réformes là
aujourd'hui on as quel paradoxe de la
situation c'est que le parti socialiste
n'a pas fait de réformes mais les rares
qui l'a fait elle était complètement
incomprise et et donc les français ont
été déçu profondément et le mark et moi
j'étais de ceux qui ont toujours dit et
je les dis au sein de l'ue dit je crois
que tous les gens partagent que ces
élections locales c'étaient les
premières élections de reconquête